So I wore my glasses simply because I forgot my
contacts. So what I want to show you is it's a
miracle watch this. It's like a magic trick.
60 to
52 yeah. All right. So but this is the real
me so you're gonna have to get get over it. All right. So let's
go and get started. This this sent t-shirt
is a prop because we've
been talking about how do I make a
disciple? Well the first
first step that we've talked about of course and make
sure step on anything here is how to identify a
disciple. First of all, they are dedicated which means they've given
their lives to Christ. They've been they've received the Holy
Spirit and now the Holy Spirit can guide them
into truth and protect them and to use
them in ways, but but now we're moving from
Developing and we went from you
know dedicated but by being born again
to developing by learning the inner character, we'll
talk about this in a minute and the outward competencies of Christ and
tonight we're talking about are they deploy deployed into
the world? And so I want to take you to the
to the this is called the high
Priestly prayer in John 17. Jesus is praying. This
is before the crucifixion. He's ours before
the crucifixion and he's praying
and he this this prayer is recorded for us and the
one verse that I wanted you to see was as he's
praying to the father. He's praying for his disciples and he
says Lord as you sent me into the
world, so I have sent them into
the world and some of you heard this story
when I was not looking to
move. I was in an excellent Church
in North Dallas and my mom fell and broke her hip
and on the same day my daughter sent me it.
Link to the job opening at Henderson
Hills and I knew of Henderson Hills years and
years and years ago because I was a youth pastor in Tulsa
and a pastor in Tulsa. I knew what God had done here over the years.
but I wasn't interested until I read the vision
statement in the mission state in the mission statement as a
we're equipping one another to love Jesus and to live and when
I saw those words live sent I thought this church
has done some heavy sledding these this is a
new way of saying let's let's get
Let's get busy with the Great Commission and it
took me back to this passage right here. What did Jesus leave
in order to come and to
be born of a virgin and to live a sinless life
and to die in our place? What did he leave?
Unless left the glory of heaven, right? This is
a Philippians 2 when we should be like Christ
who?
Who literally gave himself to become a servant and die on
a cross?
So he left the glory of heaven and he left the
the Majesty of the cosmos to become
an infant baby boy born in a trough
to lie, lying among the sheep manure
and sweat of the of The
Human Experience. That's a long way. He went
a long way for us. And so now he saying
as you sent me
I am sending them which takes which
gives the Great Commission just kind
of a very precise understanding when he says go
therefore. We know that the the
syntax of the Greek means as you
are going but whether whether you know, no
matter the syntax, this is an action word. So when
it says that we are to be deployed into
the world. I want you to see what we do
in this pathway. What's the purpose of a pathway? This
is not a hard question.
What's the purpose of a pathway?
Yes to move you from one destination to another
and so we love you and God will
take you just as you are but we're not
going to be satisfied. If you are just continuing to
come just to the worship service. You don't know anybody. You
don't speak to anyone. No one checks in on you to see
how you're doing. We're going to try to move you from one
destination to another and I was very very pleased when I
ask you to raise your hand to see if you're in a community group because I would say 90% of
you are in a community group, and that's great. But what
I'm gonna ask you to do is as you moved from
just the large worship experience into the
community group and and from the anonymous.
safety of a darken roomed all facing the
same direction Listening to A good sermon to the
anxiety of a community group where people actually want
to know your name. It's a little forward don't
you think right? But no
not only do they want to know your name. They want to help you carry your burdens.
They want to ask you where you are in your relationship
with Christ, but we can go even a step further
and remember go there for and to
All Nations make disciples. So we're
learning that these gender-based micro groups
with an intentional leader and a relational
environment and a reproducible process. This is
The Sweet Spot. This is where we want to be right here.
We will spawn one-on-one groups
and we do have already a significant number
of ladies who are in a mentor relationship, which is
fantastic. But this is where we're going to
spend most of our time on Wednesday nights. These are
the essentials.
An intentional leader. I am praying that
you will consider becoming an
intentional leader and in
doing so you'll know that it is only your responsibility by
the way. It's a program.
There's nothing wrong with programs. It's just that they don't do a great job discipling
people. Okay, a program
has to start date and the stop date and a leader and a lot of people sit
and listen and participate by just watching but an intentional
leader one day. I'm going to deptise you
we probably won't have a time when we raise our hands but
a deputize you say now, you're the intentional leader. Don't wait
for pastor Phil to call and say okay.
I've got a group for you. You're ready to go. I'm not gonna do that. All right.
I might try to put you know
somebody who wants to be discipled in a
group that's already meeting, but I'm not going to be assembling these groups
and that's the job of an intentional leader. We're
gonna talk a little bit more about that. All right and in relational environment and
a reproducible process now,
I like to recruit somebody to do this for me next
week. Okay, when I
get to the end, I'm going to ask for a show of
hands and I'm just gonna pick one of you because there'd be dozens who want to do this next
week. All right. So the large
group Jesus had a large group. We know that he
had the feeding of the 5,000 and the feeding of the four thousand, but
we also know that he had his disciples there were
12 of those but he also had the super disciples which were Peter James
and John and so we this is we see
this in the life of Jesus, but we also see in the life of
Henderson Hills. We'll have our fifth. Oops.
Coming back. Hello. We'll have our 1500 on
Sunday mornings. We'll have you know, three three or
four hundred on an equipping night. One
of I'm gonna poke fun at my
wife for a minute. We were just here a few days when we
had a great big Vacation Bible School. What do
we call it here?
Vacation Bible School, that's what
Idea, I think we should stay with that.
But we had Parents night and
people came out in droves and we
had a great opening meeting and then we went out to eat pizza. They put
the new people in the sun just so you know, so my
wife looks so pretty and you know, we're trying to make a good impression
and then we put us to feed Pizza in the Sun not a
lot of dishes went on that night. But anyway,
But but these are important these are pointing people. So why
so maybe we can get them involved in the community group and how many in a
community group well depends on the size, but I've seen as many
as 40 in a community group, but what we're asking you
to do is to move towards a micro Group, which
is three or four.
not three-fourths
three or four
and the reason is is that as the
group gets smaller the opportunity for
transparency and honesty
and even vulnerability and genuine
intimacy, which
leads to what I'm hopeful will be
accountability that increases so we're talking about
what did we just say we talked about
transparency?
We talked about vulnerability vulnerability we
talked about intimacy.
And eventually accountability and this
is a this is where we're headed. And
this is what we're hoping will happen. Again, we're talking
about movement talking about going being sent.
I want you to see as this pertains to the definition
of a disciple one who is following Jesus. That's an
action term. It's not something that I follow Jesus
when I was seven and I've been a Christian all my life. No, it's a
day by day minute by minute Breath by
breath thought by thought word by word following Jesus.
Being changed by Jesus. So one of
our maxims is that discipleship is
not about information. It's about transformation. So we're being changed by
Jesus and we're committed to the mission of Jesus making disciples.
So it's not enough just to be
discipled. We are discipled for the purpose of
becoming a disciple maker. So again, you
see the movement the scentness of this
idea that Jesus gave us and again,
I won't spend a lot of time on this in your
notebook. I I added to this disciple
profile page. I gave
you a list of bullet list of things that
you might look for when trying to identify what stage
of discipleship you're in.
Now this is important because we're all
working at becoming disciple makers which
means that we would go from the young adult stage
of Spiritual Development to the parent stage
of Spiritual Development. Now the parent then becomes
responsible for those whom God has
entrusted to him. And now what would then be a grandparent
stage of Spiritual Development? That means that
the people that I have discipled are now
discipling others.
And so you see that again that sentness that
movement that multiplicity the reproducible process.
That's where we're headed in
the right direction. Okay.
So let's let's go back now here
to Matthew 9 now, this is Jesus.
If you would read in verse 35, you would see that
he was traveling and he was taking the
gospel on the road. He was teaching
about the kingdom of God and he began
to see people in the condition that they were
in and this is what it says. When he Jesus saw
the crowds he had compassion for them.
Why
because they were harassed and helpless like
sheep without a Shepherd now if
you look at the Greek terms for
harassed and helpless, it's even worse than harassed and
helpless.
Means that they are pitiful that
they are in danger, they are like open
wound scarred. And so
when he sees people without a shepherd
He thinks to himself this is so so sad
God designed them for more than
this and this is what they've come to now before we move
to the next step to jesus' solution. Let's talk
a little bit about today.
In my lifetime and again, I'm only 50 but no,
I'm 62 in my lifetime. There
has never been as many people as lonely
and disengaged as there are
today.
As a result of rapid growth the
lengthening of life.
a multiplicity of generations in the
same culture
the development of a global pandemic forcing
people home to watch screens to have
relationships.
Simultaneously having screens where they don't
have to talk to one another. Let's just let's just be
honest for a minute how many of you've gone to a restaurant and
you've seen it two people sitting at the same time table not
talking to one another but instead they were looking at their I mean
raise your hand if you ever seen that look see we're not
we don't relate to one another anymore the the
concept of community the communal intimacy that
coin and Nia Desire with God
gave us on the inside. It's not a part of our culture any longer.
We know it in the Christian world. We
know it in the in the church life. But but what
what do you think is going on in the Heart of
Jesus now as he looks to the crowds
Same thing. This is not why how how I
created you? This is not what this is not God's
loving design. Do you father back
to the high Priestly Port? May they be one as you
and I are father are one.
You and me and I and you and but we're disengaged
we're disenfranchised and we
were living this life alone. And that has never
been God's design. So what's got what's Jesus solution very next
verse.
Then he said to his disciples.
To harvest is plentiful.
What's the Harvest?
It's the harassed and helpless people that have
no Shepherd the Sheep without a
shepherd.
The Harvest is plentiful, but the laborers are
few.
Jesus solution for the harassed
and helpless multitudes are to pray
earnestly to the lord of the Harvest to
send out laborers into the
Harvest.
So what's what is Jesus plan that Jesus jesus'
plan is to pray.
What are we to pray for?
laborers
to send I've heard this word before somewhere into the
Harvest. And so this is this has
been Jesus plan from the very beginning. So I want
to give you some a little bit more inside of
kind of a peek behind the micro group curtain. What
is it intentional leader do well building a disciple
making micro group?
A disciple making this is what you need is an intentional
leader that is not the focal point, but they
are part of the group process. One of
the things that happens in most Sunday schools.
now or life groups or Community groups
or whatever you want to call them is that they have a teacher and they
should have a teacher because that teachers signed up
and Covenant and become responsible for wanting to
to learn the lessons so that they can teach the lesson
and typically it's the teacher speaking and a
good good a really good teacher will ask
thought-provoking question open-ended questions so that people will respond
but even at the end of this lesson, we know
that the focal point of the lesson was the teacher
That's not what we're trying to do in a micro group.
Okay, a micro group has an intentional leader, but that intentional leader
is not the focal point point. They're inserting
themselves into the group as a part of the group process number
two.
The intentional leader intentionally shifts leadership from
a hierarchy.
you know at a higher hierarchy is right at the
Pope
College of cardinals priests
Bishops say I used somebody gonna help me here because I I've
been a Baptist a very long time.
You know and eventually you get down to the that's
that's a hierarchy it's very very important in Catholicism in
the cat in the Baptist Church at Henderson
Hills. We've got
the elders.
And which would include a couple of
guys on our staff of our ministerial staff our pastoral staff and
then we've got our support staff there. There's a hierarchy because it it helps
us get things done. But when we
come to a micro group,
The intentional leader is intentionally shifting
away from I am the focal point
and I am the solution to
the questions you have.
You might even know the answer.
To the question that's asked but as an
intentional leader, you'd say well, I don't know. What do you guys think?
Why are you doing that? Because you're trying to involve the group in
a group discussion. You might
have all the answers but as an intentional leader, you're not
answering all the answers. You're trying to break down that hierarchy and
make this more of a.
Of a peer relationship. Okay, two more
an intentional leader shifts from dialogue that's
conversation between two people to a dynamic interchange.
Can conversation involving the entire micro group?
There's something very very powerful when
an intentional leader. It doesn't become
the the solution person doesn't become
the the hierarchy all answer to
everyone's question. But if that intentional leader can can instead
of being the answer person point
people to Jesus.
A great question in a micro group is what do you think Jesus would do
in this situation?
You know.
Have you ever been in a situation like this? What did you do?
And and you're bringing the entire group in I think
I've told you guys this story before when David Bailey came
to my my group have a
great story about this that I can't tell because
it's still in process, but David Bailey came and he dominated the
entire micro group and I felt like
such a miserable failure because he was telling us how
he was leaving his wife and the reasons why he was leaving his wife
and why it was the right answer and we were all just
kind of sitting there and died on the inside.
And so well, I guess I'll see you guys next Tuesday. If anybody comes back, you
know, and everybody comes back and and over
a period of months. We saw through this
group dynamic and the work of the Holy Spirit. We begin
to see God do things in David's life that he himself could
not expect.
and he asked
at the IHOP at 7 AM during the
prayer request.
I don't know what God's trying to teach me.
Okay, I do.
You're not supposed to leave your wife.
She's bringing you back. He's bringing her back. You're supposed
to be that Jesus in the situation. You welcome her
with open Open Arms. You tell her how thankful you
are that God brought. I know the answer to this.
But I just waited and Rusty.
I'll never forget it.
Rusty says
he is this dull look for honestly like duh. He's
like
I've been praying for you every day since you came.
and it was like a holy spirit was just like
Man, I don't know if you've ever been in a moment where the
power of power of the Holy Spirit was so palpable, but
that's when you realize we are making
disciples.
And God is is his hand is here. And and
it is his spirit is pulsing
through the lies and the hearts and the spirits
of the people in this group. And that's that's what I'm I'm hoping
will happen for you guys.
And then lastly the intentional leader shifts the
vision from addition to multiplication.
I've been at this church
now for two and a half months. I
you probably know the answer to this. What is the number one
request for Community groups to the
community group leader.
Getting ready to guess.
We need a what?
Bigger room absolutely about 50% of
our community groups need a bigger room. Why because they need more
people.
Right. I don't blame them praise God. He's blessed
you that direction but in a micro group, we're
not as concerned with addition. Like, how
big is your micro group? We're up
to six. Well, it's too big. All right.
Well, we got eight. Let's see. We're not building. We're
not adding. What are we doing? We're multiplying we start at
the very front saying that God is going to
move us.
Closer to him and closer to
one another so that one day when we sense
that God.
grown us to the right
place as disciple makers. We're all going
to lead our own disciple group.
So from the very beginning this guy is thinking or this
gas thinking.
I could be a leader. I could be an intentional leader.
So our our focus is not on addition. Our focus
is on multiplication. Okay?
So with that, let me
see. What did I forget? Did I forget anything?
Okay. Yes.
In your notebook and I again
we're inching up on this. Alrighty.
I want to say thank you guys for coming back every week
because the very first week I split you into groups
and you're like
unexpect this
you know, and I don't know how many are here, but
it's probably a little less than the week before a little less than the week before little less than
a week before that doesn't seem that doesn't bother me that much really people
have got good reasons for coming or for
not coming but that's really not again. We're not
about addition. We're about multiplication and
so one day at the end of our
12 weeks together. We're a week five right now.
Some of you guys are going to go out on faith. And I said, I think
I'm going to do this. I think I'm gonna do this and so in the
curriculum that I've provided for you it
it gives you three steps to getting started with a micro
group. And the first one is to pray.
Ask the Lord to put on your heart the person to whom he is
drawing you to belong.
Okay, what you're looking for is a fat person and that's
an acronym for faithful available and teachable.
All right, so you're looking for someone who's faithful
available and teachable and let
me ask you this.
Anytime somebody starts a question like this, you know, the answer already is
God big enough.
Is God big enough to already have some person that you
know that needs to be discipled?
That you can pray about and when he reveals to you that yeah,
I want you to enter into her discipleship relationship
with that person is God big enough to have that person already
in mind.
curious
All you need to do is pray. Who is that father?
So that I can code to them and here's this next
step is invite.
Okay, let me let me tell you a way not to do it.
I've been to disciple making 101 and now I'm into something
maker and I'm gonna
I'm gonna ask you if you want to be in my group.
All right, because it's gonna be good. You know,
I'm really good. That's not that that's you've
forgotten everything. We said about hierarchy and
focal point and you know, what would you
do say something in your own words kind of like this?
I want you to pray about something.
That was the question. My minister of Youth asked me when I was 12 years
old.
And no one had ever asked me to pray about anything.
And so the answer was yes before. Yeah. I have nobody wanted
right, but I want you to pray about something. Will you
pray about joining me as we walk together and grow
to become better Disciples of Jesus Christ?
So it's not me doing this for you. It's us doing
this together.
Okay, I'd like to invite you to meet with me and one or
two others weekly for the purpose of the coming all
the Lord intends us to be.
and
you can finish up by saying I've been praying about this. I remember the
night. We were there on a Wednesday night and that new
that new Pastor said start praying
about it. Do you think God's a big enough? And I and you know what God put you
on my mind.
I would love for you to be in my group.
I love for us to do this together.
And because I feel like the Lord
led me to ask you this question.
That's all you have to do and then let the Holy Spirit do his work.
And then once you guys have got a group I don't care about this
three or four and I again, this is this is you're
the intentional leader you guys you decide when you meet where you meet
and how long you meet. I think you have to do at least
in an hour. Some would say an hour and a half. I think that sometimes hard to
schedule an hour and a half. But but you
just once you've got a group you start meeting and
you you decide on the location of a
relation, there are
some restaurants that you cannot have a relational environment.
And my wife and I had lunch today at a place I won't tell where it is because everybody knows
it's been what I'm talking about, but they were
having a church meeting.
And the pastor was just over there screaming as loud
as he could and Carol kept saying that I didn't
know we're coming to church for lunch. But anyway, I think
they were talking about a trip that they were wanting to take and stuff. But
but a relational environment is where you can hear one another.
And where long periods of Silence?
Are not awkward because there's so much going on, you know,
anyway, praying about that. That's that's
that is begin practicing in
your own words how you might invite somebody.